pourquoi nos chiffres vont ils seulement
de 0 à 9
pourquoi n'y at il pas un chiffre unique
pour désigner 10 puis 11
quand on y pense ça changerait tout on
compterait toujours de 0 à 10 mais il y
aurait deux chiffres après le 9
appelons-les pour faire simple ah oui
mais qui s'utilise ray avec le même
système qu'actuellement regarder à
l'écran
c'est ce qu'on appelle compte et embases
12 et c'est vrai que compter avec douche
chiffres offre au plein avantage
rien que les divisions dit part de pizza
peuvent être seulement répartis entre
une 2 5 ou 10 personnes
si vous êtes 3 tout le monde aura trois
parts mais une personne du groupe pour
une part supplémentaire ou le bâtard un
jour je me vengerai mais avec 12 part on
peut répartir facilement entre une deux
trois quatre six ou douze personnes pour
les tables de multiplication ça devient
juste magique plus de nombreux compliqué
à retenir en base 12
tout devient logique regard pour la
table de 6 c 6 0 6 0 6 0
tout s'enchaîne pour les divisions
pareil 1 / 3 on avait ce résultat
horrible 0.33 3 3 une infinité de fois
alors que embase 12 c'est super simple
ça fait 0.41 divisé par quatre en base
10 c et 0,25 mais en base 12c 0,3 si
c'est plus pratique pourquoi on ne fait
pas comme ça
vous pensez probablement que c'est parce
que nous avons juste dix doigts et que
ça s'impose à nous vous allez voir
qu'avec les mathématiques l'histoire et
la biologie c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça il existe déjà des
civilisations qui compte avec deux
chiffres avant de parler d'autres
régions du monde
je vais vous surprendre mais nous
comptons déjà avec une base de 12 une
année ces douze mois
une horloge ces 12 heures et même une
heure ces 5 x 12 minutes mais utilise 12
aussi en musique cette base et 5 altérée
alors si tout est un nombre aussi
parfait pourquoi on n'utilise pas et
bien détrompe toi
à travers l'histoire est encore
aujourd'hui la basse dose est utilisé on
en trouve dans des dialectes africains
et asiatiques par exemple ici c'est les
nombreux chez pang une petite tribu
autochtone népalaise des contreforts
montagneux de l'himalaya ceci dit c'est
difficile de trouver un vrai sigle pour
10 et 11 ans base 12
c'est plus dans le langage dans lequel
le papa du seigneur des anneaux a essayé
avec d'un langage jeune fille qu ayant
ces nouveaux longs
ici 10 et 11 non en fait la base dose a
été largement utilisé dans l'histoire
mais plutôt dans certains systèmes
spécifiques par exemple l'astronomie ou
même le commerce
quand un ancien disait mettez-moi dodoz
m2 ils comptaient en base 12 et c'est
pour cela que de très nombreuses
personnes militent pour que toute notre
civilisation passant vaste 12
il ya régulièrement des articles
scientifiques qui sortent sur le sujet
on trouve de vraies si politique de
mathématiciens qui milite pour imposer
la base 12 et ça dès la maternelle
l'un des objets de ce crime c'est ça
l'horloge base 12
je sais que ça fait peur mais il ya
toujours 12h01 les 10-11 devienne juste
des chiffres unique
au final ça change donc pas grand chose
seulement vous vous dites que la passer
en base vous demanderai de tout changer
tout changer tout changer les compteurs
de vitesse la monnaie les balances les
règles les plans ça paraît être une
tâche impossible et pourtant on l'a fait
même dans l'autre sens pour vous dire
parce que oui le disent a une histoire
et une histoire bien plus récente que
vous ne le pensez pourquoi on compte en
base 10 bah oui qui a vu cet abominable
idée d'imposer sa à tout le monde
rob a assez de lait français avant la
révolution française
il existait plus de 800 unités de mesure
en france berges toise pied pouces libre
c'était un bordel sans nom
alors à la révolution le peuple a décidé
qu'il fallait un unique système de
mesure universelle les scientifiques se
sont donc réunis et ont inventé un bleu
m c'est ce qu'on appelle le système
décimal on a choisi de tout découpé en
10 bon c'était par un choix horrible
mais on s'est rendu compte que tous les
coupés ans nous serons été plus
judicieux la période qui a suivi la
révolution fut surnommée la terreur et
sa porte bien son nom
durant plusieurs années certains
révolutionnaires en deux obsessions des
couper des têtes est découpé en bizen
l'année est passé à dix mois plus les
brumes et refreiner etc
on a fait des semaines 2 10 jours et des
horloges de 10 heures et gare à toi si
tu continue d'utiliser le système
d'ancien régime
c'était politiquement louche
fox s'est calmée bas les gens se sont
aperçus que c'était quand même moins
pratique que de diviser en 12
donc on a voulu revenir à l'ancien
régime mais c'était trop tard le 10
s'étaient imposés on l'a quand même
gardé pour mesurer le temps car on
n'avait pas pu changer toutes les
horloges ainsi que chez les commerçants
qui vendent encore les yeux ou les huit
par douzaines chez nos amis anglais
jusqu'à très récemment 1971 on comptait
encore en baisse 12 12 pence valent un
shilling 12 pouces mesure un pied et
même s'ils ont l'impression d'utiliser
maintenant un système décimal va regarde
bien les noms des nombres one two three
et ses thèmes et les veines twelve puis
on commence avec searching for chin
fifteen ils ont gardé un nom unique pour
les douze symbole de la base
néanmoins revenir à la base 12 ça paraît
être une mission impossible genre
faudrait réinventer tout les
mathématiques ou peut-être pas en effet
les mathématiques ne dépend pas de la
façon dont on compte tu l'a sûrement
remarqué mais plus tu monte en niveau en
maths et moi tu vois deux chiffres ils
sont petit à petit remplacer par des
lettres et des raisonnements
concrètement la principale chose que ça
changerait ça serait ton quotidien
rendre la monnaie calcul une réduction
au début il y aurait une habitude à
prendre mais après ça serait beaucoup
plus intuitif et rapide que la base
disent oui mais avec nos pauvres dit
doit apprendre la base 12 aux jeunes
enfants serait un enfer non
comment compter avec 12 doit compter de
10 ans disparaît être la méthode qui
s'impose à nous par la nature même
bah oui l'eau mais ont dû doigt mais
pourquoi ce chiffre pourquoi pas 12 24
ou 50
personne n'est certain de la raison
précise mais si la sélection naturelle
nous en a donné 5 c'est que ça doit être
un bon compromis
une superstar des maths alan turing le
père de l'ordinateur considérer le corps
humain comme une machine biologiques
complexes
il a montré que l'adn imposer un
algorithme de construction dont cinq
étaient le résultat le plus probable
néanmoins naître avec six doigts n'est
pas si exceptionnel
on appelle ça la polydactylie et autant
ça peut être un handicap pour certains
pourtant ça donne parfois des mains
étonnamment agile
véritable évolution mais on n'a pas tous
cette chance alors comment les anciens
faisait t-il pour compte et embases 12
avec seulement dix doigts c'est sûrement
une histoire de plier à un doigt deux
fois pour faire 6 mais non hamadouche
change complètement ta façon de compter
avec les doigts et c'est juste
incroyable repiton pouces et regarde ta
main puis ivoire 12 zones les douze
acteurs formés par des phalanges tu peux
donc les numérotés de 1 à 12 et compte
et grâce à elle et pour ôter routier en
es-tu dispose d'un pointeur totalement
naturel qui est ton pouce situe combine
cette méthode avec les deux mains tu
peux même compté jusqu'à 144 tu deviens
une calculatrice vivante
incroyable non mais attention il ya un
piège je compte en base 12 la façon dont
tu dis les nombres va changer sur des
petits nombres 12 s'est pas trop
perturbant par exemple prenons ton âge
ou quoi jouer un petit j'en donne moi en
commentaire ton agent base 12 essaye de
le faire de tête mais si tu galères il
ya des sites pour t'aider à convertir
situe à 18 ans en base 10 tu auras 16
ans en base 12 ça va faire plaisir un
certain youtuber ans comment ce pays
mais sur des grands nombres la base 12
peut être perturbante en 2012
on était en hausse de 8 on dirait un
film de science fiction
aujourd'hui en 2020 nous sommes en l'an
mil 204 et pourtant c'est pas le
moyen-âge
[Musique]
10/12 pourquoi se limiter à ça dites
vous bien qu'on n'a pas besoin de 10 un
mode différent pour compter le langage
binaire des processeurs n'utilise que 0
et un langage hexadécimal de
programmation va jusqu'à 16 sa rajoutait
des chiffres a b c d e et f
eh bien tu es jeux vidéo ne compte pas
comme toi quand tu prends de dégâts en
back office
il compte en basse 16 sur les sites
internet que tu utilises comme youtube
et codes couleurs html sont aussi en
baisse 16 6 si tu as peut-être déjà vu
avec le hashtag 2 3 à 2 b pourquoi mr
rappelle toi que l'ordinateur utilise le
binaire
or 16 est justement une puissance de 2
et c'est très pratique pour discuter
avec les machines ou regrouper les
données en paquets d'opter et ça peut
aller plus loin en bas 5040 c'est le
paradis on a des diviseurs à ne plus
savoir qu'en faire 60 au total
et c'est pas une réflexion qu'on a
seulement aujourd'hui dans le passé il
ya eu les bases 10 et 12 vient de le
voir mais y en a eu plein d'autres
d'ailleurs est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
compterait pas un peu comme si on était
en bas 16 je veux dire 14 15 16 cd non
unique
on commence à dire 17 18 19
après seize quoi pourquoi on dit pas dix
indices de 10,3 mais qu'est ce que tu
aimes baragouine parce que oui nos
nombre ne sont pas gravés dans le marbre
les civilisations ont toutes eu leur
façon de compter en dix ans 12 mais pas
seulement en inde on utilise la base 5
les mayas et les aztèques et même nos
ancêtres les celtes utilisé e la base 20
c'est de là que vient notre fameux 80 et
c'est vrai que c'est pas très logique
d'utiliser quatre fois 20 au lieu de
hoquetante comme nos amis belges et
suisses
la palme revient aux mésopotamiens qui
utilisait une base seixal ici mal base
60 alors tu te demandes peut-être
comment c'est possible
ben ils utilisaient probablement une
combinaison une main qui coupent par 5
avec les doigts et l'autre par 12 avec
les phalanges et cette base en 60 ans
l'utilisent encore pour mesurer les
minutes ou les angles et oui pour le fun
un fun mathématiques je tiens à dire on
a même inventé des systèmes de
numérotation qui ne fonctionne pas à
partir de bases mais grâce à des
compositions en facteurs et des syllabes
ce qui donne des trucs pas des poids
très bizarre d'y et novo digues et
gaveau gadi
post10 je retiens gars et enfin ge pause
10 et c'est une addition je vous laisse
imaginer la division [ __ ] matin toutes
les délires de mathématiciens là à
pardon pardon pardon
durant ce voyage j'espère vous avoir
communiqué une partie de ma passion que
sont les mathématiques et je ne compte
pas m'arrêter là car très prochainement
avec antoine on compte continuer à vous
faire rêver avec les mathématiques pour
cela il suffit de s'abonner à la chaîne
avec la petite cloche pour ne rien rater
vous pouvez aussi continuer à nous
suivre sur twitter est à suivre au néo
sur instagram et à me suivre aussi sur
mon twitter
n'hésitez pas à venir nous rejoindre sur
le disque or pour discuter entre trasher
le lien est tandis cription on remercie
les monteurs c'était ma tête je vous
remercie je vous dis à bientôt
ciao